oh boy we got a lot going on this
morning and it includes an exclusive
interview ahead of Fashion's biggest
night tonight's Met Gala the lavish
fundraiser at New York's Metropolitan
Museum of Art attracts a who's who of
celebrities and newsmakers and only on
CBS mornings Gail King sat down with
fashion Legend Anna Wintour who
co-chairs the gala and we got a sneak
peek of this year's exhibition featuring
designs by the lake Carl Lagerfeld Gil
joins us now from La Gail good morning I
am so excited to be here that's why I
want I'm so excited about this piece and
that's why I wanted to be here but
before I get started guys am I sitting
up straight because Shawna just said I
was watching you guys like this Shawna
goes Gail sit up okay
good to go Gail you are good you're
ready to roll you look like a million
dollars okay I will proceed good to see
you guys good to see you guys Anna
Wintour has been hosting this Gala for
nearly three decades now and who does
not remember some of the iconic looks
like Katy Perry with the chandelier
dress Iman glowing in Gold I love that
one and Zendaya is Cinderella but Anna
Wintour says this night really is all
about raising money for this the Met
Museum's costume Institute look at this
its annual exhibition is curated by
Andrew Bolton so we met up with a
fashionable pair for a preview that
you'll see here first
Anna Wintour has been editor-in-chief of
Vogue since 1988.
but she says taking on the Met Gala
seven years later was no walk down the
runway it was a society event people
weren't very excited about going to it
and so to take it over and and try and
make a night of it was quite
intimidating and I remember being very
happy that we raised about a quarter of
a million dollars which I thought was um
a great step forward that's a pretty
good loot for 1995. now they raise
Millions every year winter says that's
the goal of the gallon the Met Gala has
always had one Mission and that is to
raise money for the important work that
Andrew's department does at the custom
Institute this is Andrew Bolton curator
in charge of the Met Museum's costume
Institute and its annual exhibition this
year's theme Carl Lagerfeld a line of
beauty showcasing the late designer's
fingerprint on fashion this year is a
celebration of Carl's Legacy his work
and he was
um he was in the business of 65 years so
we focused on um his creativity Carl was
an amazing Sketcher everything he ever
designed over the years he began as a
drawing something Bolton says he wanted
to put on full display this was a dance
that Carl actually sketched at every
every morning that's his original dancer
during our preview we got a glimpse of
the before then days later we returned
for the after the designer's desk staged
as it appeared in his last official
photograph for Vogue back in 2018. and
it's an extraordinary picture because he
literally looks like he's sort of
Disappearing under all these papers and
books
did you do the collection in
chronological order no it's the matter
this is the only time you actually focus
on the different design houses that Cole
worked in so we have Chloe we have
Chanel we have bendy and young Carlos
all in this room all in this room when I
walk in this room my eye goes to that
talk about the work and the art
every room has what we're calling an
explosion an explosive moment say that
again every room has a sort of explosion
it's a sort of a sort of moment of
convergence between the two lines yeah
so this one you have the feminine line
with the actual matching pictures
inspired feathered dress and then you
have a 1913 Spike tuxedo so it's a
masculine and The Feminine sort of
combined into one I'm choosing this as a
moment of explosion Andrew I love this
what is this this is a wedding dress I
can't design don't you love the Santa I
do I love this particular Gallery I
think it's so romantic when this one was
made girl this particular one it was
actually the most expensive Couture
garment ever created and when you say
the most expensive what does that mean
in terms of prices
yeah in the 1996 which is which was a
lot now it's still a lot for an outfit
[Applause]
there's some beautiful dresses in here
yes that one on the in the middle there
on the top that's from his first
collection 83 years ago Chanel I could
see you wearing that in there
[Music]
I actually just wore it and uh to the
steak dinner in Washington for president
macron I have a friend you are
absolutely right you were the only one
that could say that did you hear that
and I could see you wearing that I have
yes
and see I love this straight back the
craftsmanship's extraordinary I can't
imagine what your brain has been doing
because a you have how many pieces did
you go through yeah
I think about 10 over ten thousand over
ten thousand pieces I narrowed it down
to 200 yeah it's about 200 and so I mean
you just have decision after decision
after decision don't don't you and it's
great they should come to my storyboard
and she'll say edit edit edit because it
just it starts huge and just to get I
think having it basically helps now when
I walked in this room my eye went
straight to her it's amazing
yes I love it she doesn't wear an
explosion status
as the crew added final touches we got
our true sneak peek of perhaps
lagerfell's most well-known look his own
Andrew I look at the work that you've
done to pull this off
and I saw something with you when you
were 17 and they asked you what was your
dream job oh yeah aren't you kind of
living your what was your dream job at
17. it was this it's the work yeah and
it was through work here and do what to
be curaca I was really inspired by
Harold code and Richard Martin who was
here at the time Andrew look how James
comes you know what my dream was at 17
to be asked to the prom I mean and
you're you're talking about Drew these
big I didn't have much of a social life
Carl once said that he does not see
fashion as art he once even said that
it's actually he finds it boring when
people say that but when I walk through
that exhibit today I don't know how it's
anything but art Andrew yeah I think I
need to call never light to be called an
artist he always said I was a dressmaker
and
working classes I'm working class
because he worked so hard what was
amazing about Carl he knew so much about
history but he was always focused on the
future so I think that's probably a
little bit to do with you know his
contradictions he was an historian but
is also intensely modern and looking
forward
and some some would say the choice of to
honor Carl lagerfel is a bit of a
surprising Choice critics have said we
should not be celebrating someone who
made fat phobic races sexist comments
throughout his career well obviously
kha was a complicated man and I think
Andrew's decision really to focus on the
work and not it's not a biography it's
there are documentaries and books that
cover all sides of Carl's life we're
really focusing on his work when you
hear some of the things he said at one
point he talked about Adele's weight
he's he said no one wants to see a curvy
woman he said the of the metoo movement
I'm fed up with it in 2018 when you hear
comments like that and there's a long
list of them what do you all think how
do you reconcile that with what we're
going to say call is provocative and he
was full of paradoxes and I think
sometimes he would say things Gail to
shock and not necessarily things that he
believed in and obviously them and there
are things that he has said that Andrew
and I do not agree with but I think when
we go back and we look at the work that
he has created over so many years I I
think that deserves celebration it
deserves acknowledgment I think it will
be the
extraordinary interest in this
exhibition they say Anna it's called the
Met Ball but it's been referred to as
Anna's party do you see it that way no
it's the Mets party and in the end we're
trying to raise the funds and we're
trying to bring people into the museum
and we hope they have a good time too I
know everybody that comes has a great
time but everybody Anna always goes on
and on about the guest list what goes
into your thinking about the guest list
we're always interested in trying to
reflect a cultural moment and what we
feel is is happening at the world at any
given time do you find Anna you're
getting calls from people you haven't
heard from in years uh well my phone is
on mute
and and how do you handle the request
and how do you
because I would imagine there are some
hurt feelings with people that say you
know Anna how could I not come how could
you not let me in how do you handle I
mean obviously every every year is
different and we try and create the
guest list in a way that makes sense for
for whatever the theme of the exhibition
is and every year we try and and make it
a little make it different have
different people come so
obviously there's always next year
the exhibition you just got a little
snippet of opens to the public this
Friday at the Met and I encourage
everybody because as much as we like the
Razzle and Dazzle of what's going to
happen on the red carpet tonight that's
always exciting the main money the main
reason is both Andrew and Anna stress
was about raising money for this
glorious institution and it is really
really dazzling so this Monday listen
I'm I'm leaving here and flying right
back to New York but guess what none of
us are going tonight
we can all we can all take the there's
always next to your approach but I
appreciated your question
yeah I love that Andrew's living is his
dream uh and you know you put the
question to to Anna about the guest list
and she answered it by saying my phone
is on mute yes I know she's a smart girl
that Anna winter because the legend goes
and Anna approves the guest list and the
guest of the guest and when I asked her
that she said no no no Gail it's a team
effort I go I'm going to take that as a
yes it's but it's always it's always a
very fun event always it sure is all
right Gail thanks for getting up with us
yeah all right get some sleep we'll see
you again bye